you know it's pride month for lgbtq and
then Gary says to me you know JD wants
to kiss Chris Wilding on the mouth for
um pride month it was really weird
because I put up a note like as a joke
saying I'll go in the studio and make
out with JD for pride month and no one
picked up on it no one said anything and
then I'm out in the hall and JD makes a
point of coming up to me and going ah I
wouldn't have made all of you
I would have kissed you you know on the
lips
for Pride I give up heck which I'm like
Amazed by yeah me too like I mean
I don't know what his deal is the reason
what is it um being an ally so there it
is yeah that sort of thing JD you are a
real friend to the gay community you
truly are you really gotta be bringing
out positive things for people you know
whether it be tongue are you gonna uh no
no I don't know if he doesn't want I
want to caress your head a little bit I
gotta caress my head no this is good
what do you think you're gonna get away
with a peck JD he's gonna think that
you're proud listen you want to be proud
you better let them play with your tits
too
can I rub you a little bit
can there be a little foreplay to the
kids Speedo oh you know what I regret
saying anything you know I haven't said
anything I'm trying to First do you
think do you think JD has a big [__] yes
I've often commented a big nerd [__] and
when I saw him in the speedo in Miami
can you make sure to say that well I
have one too a lot was confirmed by the
outlines in the panty area if I may have
a speedo yes yes yes yes it's average JD
what happens if you kiss Chris and you
start to chub up a little bit and you
realize you have more than just a Jason
gay pride but you in fact are gay oh I'm
not going to chub up but you know listen
oh please
I'm a really good kisser dude you'll be
like Katy Perry I Kissed the boy and I
liked it
you're very I'm gonna say something
about JD he's very Progressive I mean I
do
all right well in honor of pride month
here is JD showing solidarity with Chris
Wilding Chris is going to give JD a gay
kiss do you want to lead or I'll lead uh
I don't know it could like lead together
okay who's the top and who's the bottom
there's no bottom yes there is it's good
no equal parties all right Chris you're
a little more experienced at this than
JD why don't you lead all right here we
go you ready yes
Jesus Christ
what happened JD he had an open mouth
his mouth his lips are definitely more
open
how'd you like it and you like the kids
that was weird you know it was whatever
it was fine I'm a good kisser you can be
honest it was fine in that sense it's
just weird it's that it's you any
arousal uh whatsoever no there's no I'm
not get out of here you know what it is
he pushed me away because it got real it
got real Chris yeah he jumped
yeah
because I felt his lips starting to open
up like a little while that's how I kiss
I mean that's just my kissing style I'm
really surprised what is that music
we're gay now we hear this
is the boy and you like it
Cherry
you know what happened when I kissed him
my lips were all tingly because of his
beard and his facial hair I love that
thanks guys in honor of Pride JD way to
go there we go
uh a true Ally of the game more allies
please thank you
foreign